okay so the topic of this updated video
is mitosis and the cell cycle so let's
get started well let's go ahead and
begin with kind of a brief overview on
what the cell cycle is it's the
repeating set of events in the life of a
cell you know when cells are alive they
have functions to perform so as they're
going through their life they're
performing these functions and every now
and then they pause and they stop from
their functions in order to perform a
process known as mitosis but when we
look at this pie graph here we can see
that the cell cycle can be broken down
into stages and so stage on the first be
an interphase when we look at the pie
graph here interphase takes up the vast
majority of the cell cycle
but interphase itself can be subdivided
into three sub categories when we look
at the g1 stage we're going to go into
more detail in a moment but it's the
first stage of interphase followed by
the S stage which is the second stage of
interphase followed by the g2 stage
which is the third stage of interphase
so when you look at the time spent
during interphase and the pie graph you
can see interphase takes up the vast
majority of the life of a cell and then
the cell will pause from interphase and
it'll quickly go through mitosis and
then we come to a stage called prophase
and metaphase anaphase and telophase and
these can be seen at the top of our
picture here collectively these are what
make up the stages of mitosis and the
majority of this video is going to talk
about what happens not just during the
cell cycle but more specifically what
happens during mitosis so let's look at
that next so now then what is mitosis
well it's a type of cell division that
involves somatic or non sex cells
examples of somatic non sex cells would
be like near neurons your nerve cells
red blood cells white blood cells
and even skin cells in fact the vast
majority of the body is made up of
somatic cells cells that are not
involved in reproduction and so this is
a visa the cells that are made by
mitosis they're somatic cells and if we
could examine their chromosomes at a
stage in the life we can actually
examine the chromosomes of the cells and
we would discover them to be diploid on
this picture here here's a karyotype
that shows diploid chromosomes notice
how there's two chromosome number ones
and two chromosome number eight two
chromosome number 17 s because the
chromosomes are arranged in pairs
we call these diploid chromosomes and so
the cells where are those diploid as
well
now mitosis it's worth noting that in
some forms of organisms and some forms
of life it's kind of a form of asexual
reproduction now the way bacteria
multiply the way Protista and fungi
multiply it's kind of a variation of
mitosis but it's it's one way that they
can produce another individual organism
and so the end result of mitosis we're
gonna start with like in my picture here
we're gonna start with one cell now as
the act of mitosis proceeds ultimately
by the end we're gonna create what are
called daughter cells so the two cells
created at the end are basically
identical copies of one another and
genetically identical and are known as
daughter cells so we're gonna go through
this process in a little more detail now
well let's start out with the process
known as interface and so interphase as
we saw earlier in that pie graph is
gonna be divided into three sub stages
number one the first being the g1 stage
now the G kind of stands for a growth or
gap and so in this stage this is where
the normal functions of the cell are
performed you know if it's a cell of
your stomach then the normal function
would be to be secreting digestive
enzymes that help break down the food
that you've eaten so the normal
functions of a cell are performed
eventually the cell will begin to grow
you know it will create additional
organelles additional ribosomes for
example additional lysosomes
for example after all the cells about to
divide into two so you kinda have to
make more parts to accommodate both
cells and ultimately then we come to the
second stage known as a vs stage and the
S kinda stands for synthesis
now the word synthesis just means to
make or to copy something and in this
case DNA the active version of DNA
called chromatin watching my picture see
the the six colorful squiggly lines
pretend those are pieces of DNA during
the S stage dint identical copies of
those are created so for a short time
cells actually have double the amount of
DNA and this is because of the s stage
of interphase and then well eventually
if there's a g1 stage you can kind of
figure out eventually there's a g2 stage
this is the second growth stage or some
people call the second gap stage and so
here we have the cell begins to grow and
again it's performing its normal
functions but ultimately the cell is
gonna be preparing next to enter mitosis
now before we get into actual mitosis
here's a kind of a just a picture an
artist drawing of interphase and what do
we see well we see that the nucleus is
intact
now that's a telltale sign right there
that this is a drawing of an interphase
cell in this picture right here there's
about you know a couple dozen cells in
this picture many of the cells in this
picture are interphase cells for example
here's an interphase cell and here's
another interface sailin here's another
interface cell notice how all there the
nucleus is still intact
well now let's shift focus and move on
into prophase the first step of mitosis
so the DNA the loose stringy version of
DNA called chromatin will start to coil
into these familiar X shaped looking
chromosomes so now you can see there's
two red chromosomes in the picture two
green chromosomes in the picture and two
black
chromosomes well that's because one from
mom and one from dad one of the black
chromosomes you inherited from mom one
of the black chromosomes you inherited
from dad
same for the two Reds same for the two
greens and eventually the nucleus begins
to dissolve and thus the chromosomes
kind of get spilled into the cytoplasm
of the cell
and ultimately objects called spindle
fibers begin to grow and begin to form
and you're gonna see the function of
them in a moment in this picture right
here an artist drawing is a few things
that you can see that kind of give away
that this is a drawing of prophase
number one you can see spindle fibers
forming another thing that gives it away
is you can see the nucleus is dissolving
and another part that gives it away you
can see X shaped chromosomes are
beginning to form well here's a picture
of again about a dozen or a couple dozen
cells some of these actually are in
prophase and I think there's two
pictures two cells in particular they
really stand out for prophase this
picture right here in this picture
notice how the nucleus is beginning to
dissolve and the in it's looking like
there's some chunky objects forming
inside of the cell or those are the
chromosomes forming well when we move on
into metaphase we've now come to the
second stage of mitosis and this is
where those spindle fibers that were
created during prophase what they do is
they attach themselves to the centromere
location of the chromosomes and then
they spend the fibers start to pull the
chromosomes to these cells equator the
middle line of the cell right there
they're all kind of lined up in the
middle of the cell that's a telltale
signature of metaphase in this artist
drawing right here you can see hey
there's all the chromosomes lined up
along the equator line of the cell
that's again a telltale characteristic
of metaphase in this picture right here
I think if you look there's you can
probably argue maybe two cells I think
this one right here and this cell right
here the top one you know you could
probably are
Evette maybe this is actually right at
the end of metaphase and at the
beginning of the next step but for a
lack of better options and these
pictures right here you can see a lot of
the chunky chromosomes are still kind of
along the middle of the cell
definitely the one on the bottom is a
better characteristic representation of
metaphase well now let's move on into
anaphase the third step of mitosis and
the spindle fibers begin to pull the
chromosomes in opposing directions
remember one chromosome is made from two
chromatids so when the grow when the
chromosomes are being split apart one
chromatid will be pulled to the left one
chromatid will be pulled to the right
one chromatid of each chromosome where
we pulled leftward and one will be
pulled right word and in this picture
right here you can see that the two
chromatids are being pulled apart from
one another one chromatid being pulled
to the left one chromatid to the right
also you can see the spindle fibers
drawn as the blue threads in this
picture and those are the one the
spindle fibers are the parts that are
actually doing the pulling in this
picture right here if you look closely I
think you could probably only find one
picture of an interphase cell and there
it is you can see that half of the
chunky purplish objects are being pulled
to the left and the other half to the
right when we move on when we move on
into telophase next we have our fourth
stage of mitosis and so the spindle
fibers their function now fulfilled
begin to dissolve and break down
cytokinesis we're gonna talk more about
this in a moment but cytokinesis the
dividing or the splitting of the
cytoplasm begins to occur and the cell
begins the basically separate into two
the nucleus begins to regrow and reform
surrounding the genetic material and now
let's focus on the genetic material
those are still chromatids but the
chromatids are gonna unwind back into
the loose stringy
their version of DNA called chromatin
and that's one of the other events of
tila phase and so the end result we now
have two cells diploid and we would call
these two daughter cells in this drawing
right here here's an early picture an
early stage of telophase right here we
see that the two nuclei are beginning to
regrow in this picture there's actually
several pictures of cells several cells
in this picture that I think you could
make a really good argument are in are
in telophase I think this one right here
could be a good argument see how there's
two lumps of genetic material at the
left and right side of the cell I think
this picture right here and I think this
picture right here these are three good
representations it's probably even a few
others you could find in this picture as
well but I thought these three that I
highlighted in yellow a real good
symbolic examples of telophase well a
moment ago I brought up cytokinesis I
want to say a few more things about it
cytokinesis the dividing of the
cytoplasm in animals it's a little
different than plant cells animal cells
you know have an outer cell membrane and
because it's a flexible cell membrane it
it just begins the pinch inward and
inward and inward until eventually the
two cells separate but in plants it's
not like that plants you might recall
have an outer boundary to the cell
membrane they have what's called a cell
wall very stiff and rigid cell wall so
just pinching inward is just not
possible
so what happens is they a plate begins
to form some membrane vesicles begin to
form in the middle and they start to
grow outward and as the process
continues here's their our cell plate
beginning to form as the process
continues some membrane vesicles just
keep adding on to the cell plate and you
can see the cell plate begins to form
from the inside and then slowly expands
outward until eventually to
new cells have been created and are
separated from one another all right as
we start to wrap up this video in this
picture I've highlighted in the yellow
box is that cell would you say that's an
interphase prophase metaphase anaphase
telophase cell I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
well I hope you realize well there's two
there's chromatids being pulled to the
top and bottom of the cell and so I hope
you see that is a clear picture of
anaphase well how about this example
right there is that cell in yellow
interphase prophase metaphase anaphase
and telophase I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
well I hope you see just a normal
looking cell with a nucleus intact and
so I hope you would call this interface
there's a lot of interphase cells if you
browse through this picture there's many
other interphase cells in this picture
as well how about this picture right
here in the yellow box would you say
interphase prophase metaphase anaphase
telophase and I hope you said well I
hope you can see there's two cells
almost fully formed you can see a
dividing line down the middle of the two
so I hope you said hey you know what
that's a pretty good telophase picture
right there well how about this picture
right here in the yellow box is that
interphase prophase metaphase anaphase
telophase well I hope you see the
nucleus dissolving right there and as a
result came to the conclusion of
prophase and lastly how about this one
in the yellow box interphase prophase
metaphase anaphase of telophase I think
the chromosomes are mostly aligned along
the equator or the middle line of the
cell and I hope you then thought
metaphase okay now go ahead and pause
the video and try to answer these eight
questions I'm gonna go over the answers
in three two one
okay so name the
step that sell a is in hope you said
prophase
how about Selby I hope you said
interface
how about cells see I hope you said
telophase
how about cell D help you said anaphase
in these drawings I don't really see a
good metaphase example in these drawings
question number five in which cell a B C
or D is the nucleus dissolving or that
happens during prophase so I hope you
realized picture a number six in what
cell can you find evidence of
cytokinesis and the cytoplasm dividing
well I hope you realize that cytokinesis
mainly takes place during telophase so
picture see number 7 in which cell are
the sister chromatids being separated
when D the chromatids beat era when are
they pulled to opposite ends of the cell
that's during anaphase so I hope you
said D and question number 8 in which
cell would this I'll be performing its
normal functions or the normal functions
are performed during interphase so I
hope you said pick sugar be okay and so
if that was if you want some more
practice go ahead and pause the video
and try to answer these questions here
if you're in my biology class feel free
to put your answers on a separate sheet
of paper and see me before class or
after class one day and I'd be happy to
check your answers thanks for watching
and I hope you found this helpful